باستخدام الذكاء الاصطناعي غير محتال صيني
شكله وانتحل شخصيه صديق رجل اعمال لينتزع
منه اكثر من نصف مليون يورو ووافقه وكانت
الصحافه الفرنسيه ضحيه اوضح انه تلقى في
ابريل مكالمه عبر الفيديو من شخص بدا
شبيها شكلا وصوتا باحد اقاربه واخبره
بحاجته الى مبلغ من المال لكن الشخص الذي
كان يتحدث معه كان في الواقع محتالا
استخدمت تقنيه ذكاء الاصطناعي لتعديل
ملامح وجه ناجح في اقناع رجل الاعمال
بتحويل 600 الف دولار من الحساب المصرفي
لشركه وبعدما حول رجل الاعمال المبلغ بعث
برساله الى صديقه الذي انتحلت هويته وطبعا
عندما ادرك الخطا الذي اقترفه
اطالب الشرطه التي امرت المصرف بوقف عمليه
تحويل تمكن من
السرداب 1000 فيما لم يتم التوصل بعد
لهويه المسؤول عن عمليه الاحتيال
[موسيقى]